have you ever heard of a company called
tsmc
while most people have never heard about
tsmc all of us are extremely dependent
on the company as of july 2020 tsmc
controlled 51 of the entire global chip
market
tsmc founder morris chang drew a big
crowd at his first public address of the
year on wednesday speaking at the taipei
forum chang gave his view on why taiwan
is successful in the global chip sector
when you look at consumer electronics
the numbers are just even higher in
terms of iphones super computers and
automotive ai chips tsmc is responsible
for 92 percent of production while
samsung controls the remaining 8 percent
considering their monopoly on the
semiconductor market i don't think you'd
be surprised to hear that they're the
tenth largest company in the world
coming in at 607 billion dollars
yet the general public has never heard
of tsmc so here's how tsmc became the
king of semiconductor manufacturing
taking a look back the story of tsmc
dates back nearly a hundred years to a
man named morris chang who was born on
july 10 1931 in ningbo chakyang a lot of
morris's formative years were during the
height of world war ii so his family
found themselves constantly moving
around china toward areas of conflict
initially they moved from ningbo to
british hong kong and this is where
morris would attend primary school but
by the time he was 11 japan would invade
and overtake hong kong which forced the
family to move to shanghai then back to
ningbo and then to chongqing
this lasted for a couple of years but in
1948 the chinese civil war would break
out and the family would move to hong
kong once again
fortunately for morris though he was
about to turn 18 which meant that he
could attend college in a much more
stable area morris initially wanted to
be a writer or a journalist but his
father convinced him that engineering
was a much more stable path and with
that morris would move to the us and
attend harvard university he only stuck
around at harvard for one year though as
he would transfer to mit during his
second year morris would get his
bachelor's in mechanical engineering in
1952 and he would instantly turn around
and get his masters as well in 1953.
morris also pursued a doctoral degree
from mit but he would eventually quit in
1955 after his thesis was rejected
multiple times
given that morris already had a
bachelor's and a master's in engineering
though it wasn't that hard for him to
find a job
in 1955 morris joined sylvania
semiconductor and he would work there
for three years before switching over to
texas instruments and this is where he
would spend the majority of his working
days unlike many entrepreneurs who
started business during college or after
a couple of years of work morris sells
his job until it was basically time to
retire he slowly worked his way up the
corporate ladder and stayed at texas
instruments for 25 years
in 1961 texas instruments sponsored
morris's phd in electrical engineering
from stanford and i think this is what
really got morris to stick around
after receiving his phd morris got
promoted to vice president and
eventually president of ti
it wasn't until 1983 that morris left ti
when he was offered a job as ceo at
general instrument corporation he only
stuck around for a year though before he
quit in 1985.
at this point morris was 55 years old
and i'm sure he made plenty of money as
an engineer and executive so he could
have easily retired but instead he
decided to partner with taiwan and
phillips and found tsmc in 1987.
by the time tsmc was created though
legacy players like intel ti and nec
dominated the market and given that it
took years to develop and manufacture
advanced semiconductors the barrier to
enter the industry was quite high
but on the bright side if you were able
to cross that barrier you had a great
shot as band value doesn't mean that
much in this industry after all
consumers don't know or care about where
these chips come from so electronics
companies just choose the most cost
effective supplier tsmc's first chips
were two process nodes or basically two
generations behind the competition but
morris was able to make this work by
pricing the semiconductors ahead of the
cost curve in other words morris took a
loss at the beginning in order to
attract customers and he leveraged
economies of skill to turn a profit
while simple in theory this idea was
extremely controversial in the 1980s as
it was extremely difficult to reach said
economies of scale
so morris was making a massive gamble
with the strategy but given that he was
backed by taiwan and phillips he had
some pretty deep pockets
within four to five years morris was
able to reduce the gap between tsmc and
the legacy players to just one process
node and around the same time morris
would take tsmc public in 1993 through
the taiwan stock exchange
four years later tsmc would become the
first taiwanese company to be listed on
the new york stock exchange
with the help of the public markets and
the irrational.com bubble morris was
able to continue his super aggressive
strategy throughout the 1990s and tsmc
would catch up to the legacy players by
the end of the century
tsmc had finally broken into the
semiconductor industry and they could
have taken it easy by simply keeping up
with the competition but maurice had no
plans of slowing down thus far he had
dedicated the company's efforts into
catching up to the competition and now
he was going to pour in all of their
effort into becoming the global leader
given that he was over 70 years old
though morris would hand over the
position of ceo to rick sai
under rick's leadership tsmc continued
to rapidly innovate their chips in fact
between 2006 and 2008 rickovers are the
company's biggest sleeping manufacturing
from 65 nanometer chips to 40 nanometer
chips but despite this fast progress
tsmc didn't grow all that much during
this time period as the global ship
industry was experiencing a massive
recession following the dot-com bubble
and it didn't take long for the 2008
financial recession to roll around but
morris actually saw great opportunity
through this recession he witnessed the
emergence of mobile technology like
smartphones and tablets and he was
extremely excited to be part of this
revolution
in fact morris was so excited and he saw
so much opportunity that he would return
as ceo in 2009 at age 78. it looks like
morris's primary goal with returning to
tsmc was to make a deal with apple and
in 2011 this would become a reality as
apple agreed to begin trial production
of the a5 and a6 chips with the dsmc
from there it didn't take long for apple
to commit to working with the tsmc for
the long term and today apple accounts
for 25 of tsmc's entire revenue
anyway after the apple partnership was
solidified orris announced that he was
going to retire in 2013 and make rick
ceo again but when 2013 actually came
around morris decided to stick around
for even longer not only was the mobile
space exploding but nvidia and amd were
about to go on their own exponential
runs
nvidia started embracing the machine
learning and ai industries in the
mid-2010s as the pc market started to
stagnate
in the meantime amd was basically
employing morris's strategy of pricing
chips ahead of the cost curve with ryzen
and this turned out to be a massive
success and revitalized the pc industry
to make things even better bitcoin
exploded in 2017 which resulted in crazy
high demand for nvidia and amd gpus for
crypto mining rigs and given that tsmc
is the supplier for nvidia apple amd and
everyone else you can think of this boom
directly carried over to tsmc
tsmc managed to breakthrough.com highs
in late 2016 and profits start to grow
exponentially once again
and with that morris would finally
retire in june of 2018 at age 86.
after morris left mark lew served as
co-ceo became ceo and chairman over the
next few years though tsmc started to
stagnate once again
and though this makes mark look bad it's
really not his fault morris is just
really good at leaving at the peak
anyway though the company's goals slow
down for a few years once a pandemic and
supply shortage hit tsmc would go
parabolic once again
however the supply shortage has not been
all good for tsmc
sure their profits and stock prices have
gone to the moon but the shortage has
also drawn a lot of attention towards
tsmc's monopoly basically the entire
chip shortage circles back to tsmc and
it's not particularly a good thing that
one company has so much influence so
many governments around the world have
been trying to diversify chip production
for example former president donald
trump pressured tsmc into building a 12
billion manufacturing plant in phoenix
similarly tsmc agreed to open a research
and development facility in japan
in the meantime the european union is
trying to beat tsmc to two nanometer
production but this is going to be
extremely difficult tsmc themselves are
only on three nanometer production and
they've never slowed down their
innovation momentum
according to peter hanbury if you want
to compete against dsmc onto an animator
you're going to have to spend 15 billion
this year then 18 billion next year and
then 20 billion dollars a year after
that and that's just three nanometers
the european union wants the btsmc to
two nanometers the problem is that as
technology continues to improve it
becomes exponentially harder and more
expensive to take the next step so it's
basically impossible to just step in and
compete against tsmc you would likely
need a budget of 100 billion dollars to
beat tsmc to 2 nanometers in a short
period of time and though the eu can
technically afford that it's unlikely
that they'll actually make such a large
investment as more time goes by though
it'll just become even harder to
challenge tsmc so maybe that you will
bite the bullet but we'll just have to
wait and see
while tsmc is no doubt a monopoly it
could be argued that tsmc has thus far
been an ethical monopoly they haven't
voluntarily jacked up prices or slowed
down innovation or been involved in any
sort of corruption even though all of
these would have been super easy given
their influence and control tsmc is
actually extremely strict about ethics
and integrity just a few months ago they
fired seven employees for leaking
information about apple's upcoming chips
since morris founded tsmc the company
has centered around four core values
which include integrity commitment
innovation and customer trust
while these sounds super cliche tsmc's
history over the past 34 years has shown
that tsmc has indeed upheld these values
i mean just take a look at how nvidia
ceo jensen huang talks about tsmc
because i think that moore's
his career
his philosophies
tsmc
its strategies
its core values
is absolutely
a study
in industrial revolution
there is no question about it hearing
that i think it's pretty clear that the
world's biggest companies don't work
with dsmc because they have to but
because they want to and as long as
that's the case maybe the tsmc monopoly
isn't all that bad do you guys think
that something has to be done about tsmc
comment that down below also drop like
if you're grateful for tsmc's chips and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you